I haven't done one of these in a while
but this is going to be a live episode
of the beginner to master Speed Run
episode number
19 I posted number 18 just a few hours
ago I'm currently on a streak of 64 wins
a very interesting streak rating is
and let's get into it first opponent
playing Brad
arol uh uh let's
play let's play chess let's play
E5 oh we have a Vienna okay so I
encountered the Vienna the last
episode and yeah exactly this position I
had the last episode this is a VI Gambit
D5 is a very important move to know to
Counterattack the
center and the main line usually goes
takes and then
takes this opponent is thinking
so maybe not used to encountering this
move
D5 I mean there are other possible
captures for white there's Knight takes
Pawn takes if Pawn takes I'm likely to
then take on
F4 white doesn't take anything white
plays
D3 so giving me the option to really
choose which Pawn I want to take so this
is the first point in the game I'm on my
own like I've I'm out of any sort of
Prior open
knowledge the first move that comes to
mind is Pawn takes
E4 but that would walk into Pawn takes
E5 then my Knight's
attacked and then White's probably then
ready to
recapture so yeah interesting move Pawn
D3 don't think I've seen this one
before can consider Bishop G4 develop
and attack the
queen could play Knight C6 to reinforce
the center there's also so Pawn takes
Pawn which might walk into this
move
H I'm taking time here
to like try and figure out what to
do and D4 is another
option which then is likely met with
Knight
E2 and then I can reinforce maybe Knight
C6 yeah I'm going to go for D4 I think
this is probably one of the more solid
simple
approaches like a space make this knight
move
again the position is probably fine for
white like after Knight E2 but then
white might have a a clunky time on the
king side especially developing the
bishop now I should note here that white
could also consider counterattacking by
taking on E5
and then if takes and then takes it's a
big trade I can activate the queen most
likely I'm very curious to check this
opening after the
game yeah this does resemble a French
type advanc variation but usually in the
French it's uh like the pawn chain is
facing the other
direction the pawn chain is pointed
toward towards the king's side this case
it's pointed towards the queen
side so yeah let's continue developing
Knight C6 defending the
pawn now if white wants to White could
play Pawn
F5 and really just close down the
center and then we'll get a situation
where the focus of play will likely
shift the
wings like white would then maybe look
to play on the king's side I'd look to
play on the Queen's side
there's a general principle think I gave
a few episodes ago usually you want to
focus on the side where your Pawn chain
is pointing
towards so it's more likely I'll try and
focus on the Queen's
side Knight
F3 Knight
F3 putting more pressure on the pawn I
probably have to take
now Bishop D6 is a move but then the
problem is after takes D4 as a
Target so let's go for
this and white has a choice whether to
take back with Knight or
Bishop I'm imagining I'll probably
develop this bishop here and this bishop
to E6 or
G4 and get some nice Harmony in the
center minor pieces will be uh
uh decently
placed but okay white trying to disturb
my Harmony Pawn E5 I mean it would be
really nice if I can just teleport my
knight here so the moves that come to
mind are Knight G4 and Knight
D5 Knight
D5 allows white to
take I'm going to go for Knight D5
there's a a nice variation if white
takes on
D4 I can take
take and then Queen
H4 meanwhile I am threatening probably
to play Knight
E3 I mean White's probably best off
recapturing on
F4 o but I think white is falling for
the trap
now and we we see the downside of
White Moving the F Pawn early and then
leaving the king side a little bit
neglected cuz now Queen
[Music]
H4 a few moves ago I I was not sure
about the position but
now yeah I think White's going
to really be suffering and there's three
legal moves G3 King E2 and King
D2 King D2 might be the best
try
I can play Queen F2 attacking the knight
and
king also there's Bishop C5
first let's go for Queen
F2 because yeah if the Knight moves back
I'll have a a pleasant
choice either Knight
[Music]
E3 Knight E3 is actually I think the
easiest line to calculate because it
almost traps the queen it would force
the queen here and then I can take and
then take here and Fork once the king is
driven to
E1 um I'm going to take a moment to look
for better options
but yeah let's just go for
this Wis
[Music]
material it's not going to win the game
right away assuming white doesn't
resign um but it will trade Queens it'll
win The Rook on A1 to simplify a little
bit so yeah after this game I'll analyze
opening a little bit take a look at
uh maybe what I should have done better
also what white should have done better
white was probably fine
like in the
opening okay got my
Fork yeah it's definitely a position
white can still try and play on like my
knight is perhaps likely to get
trapped although I can I can start with
this move Bishop to
B4 and try to drive the king away from
covering
[Music]
C2 and now I have Bishop
G4 developing my Bishops to attack
White's
King I like this
[Music]
move the bishop E2 I'm happy to
trade and then okay if King takes I can
save the Knight
which I'll
[Music]
do I was going to say if Knight takes
then I would Castle Queen side to attack
the the D
Pawn
ooh white attacking
this C6 doesn't help because still
Knight
[Music]
C7 Bishop's also attacked but it's
defended by the
Knight
so Castle Queen side
to defend and to attack multi-purpose
move and yeah really just the goal is to
get the pieces into the game especially
both
Rooks and do some trades if possible
like if takes takes that would be
nice and ideally I want to start going
after these Center
pawns as on the half
files okay white uh probably missing the
fact that Bishop can move backwards
not quite seeing the whole board
there so actually ended up being a
pretty smooth game at least once I got
this queen H4 move
in and sometimes this is how you you win
at this raing level you you just follow
principles be patient and wait for the
opportunity to
strike um and my opponent kind of just
walk into the the Tactical sequence I
mean this this looked like a safe move
at first glance but just didn't quite
sense a
danger so going back in the opening I'm
really curious what I should have played
in this
position
um stockfish says that D4 is the second
best move but the best move is actually
to
take which I was hesitant to do because
this move looks
scary ah but in this position there's a
really key move not to move the Knight
but to
play I I'll give twitch Shad a chance to
try and find it or people watching the
future on YouTube black to
move Sometimes the best
defense is
attack yeah good job to everyone saying
D4 and and what this does it
counterattacks the Knight it frees the
square for this Knight so if this Knight
moves let's say E4 I can move here
defending preparing this and then
otherwise if takes I
take and I mean Black's up a pawn ready
to
activate it looks crazy but this is just
uh better for
black
so yeah white was doing fine here
EV valbar says like close to
equal E5 was maybe the first misstep and
then taking was a big
misstep
um yeah white should white should just
take back here and it would have been a
fight Bishop takes maybe
preferable okay so that was game number
one one person was asking in twitch chat
how does a knight
move uh feel free to Google it but let's
move on to game number two of this
episode playing GS
shoer from the
USA and playing
E4 and for most of this uh speedrun
series I've been sticking with the same
set of openings at some point I might
mix things up um H6 is a move
usually indicates that black is scared
of the potential Knight
G5 um the problem with H6 it's a little
bit slow to develop the king side gives
me time to strike in the
center yeah maybe we can call this the
anti- fried
liver but um yeah black playing really
quickly Pawn C5 attacking the
queen going to take a moment here
because there's a few options for the
queen like check or this and this would
R
mate few ways to make threats I don't
think these moves are so useful though
like Queen here it's just asking
to for black to defend and then probably
to
attack so I'm a bit more inclined to
maybe play a move like Queen
D3 just a nice looking Square Queen D2
would block the bishop Queen D1 look
passive black playing very quickly
here now one point I want to make is
that when black plays
C5 this Pawn can't move backwards so
this square is uh going to be a probably
key Square for the
Knight if I move here right away then we
trade
but the eventual Prospect of Knight D5
would be nice here I'm actually thinking
Knight
B5 to just threaten the
fork and black could take the pawn but I
would get in Knight
[Music]
C7 and sometimes like when you're
considering a move like this the
opponent will have an easy defense but
in this case I don't see an easy defense
for
black like the Queen's not on d8 and
it's kind of far away from helping out
and King d8 now black has lost casting
rights um but this move does I guess
defend and now black is attacking
E4 F3 is not legal because I'm
pinned
so
yeah kind of a weird
spot E5 looks really
nice
E5 I might allow the queen trade though
like Queen E4 would would be possible
there and especially with black losing
casting rights I don't want to allow
black to trade Queens so
easily so what I'm going to do here is
just move back to
C3 I think the Knight served its purpose
provoking the king to
move and now it's just more useful in
defending the pawn
again now yeah I'd like to develop I
really want to play Bishop F4 but Queen
takes F4 so I'll start with
G3 attacking the
queen it does allow this but the plan
would be to play Bishop
F4 and get some attack against D6
I was also going to say that it's very
likely that castling Queen side will
come eventually although I can't legally
Castle here because the queen controls
D1 King
D7 black again defending with a
king uh there's a really attractive move
here
which yeah generally when you're when
you're applying pressure I mean
obviously D6 is a focal point you just
want to add more attackers Rook D1 is
one option Knight B5 is an option to
move back but uh I think
E5 is just the most devastating for
black attacking the Knight attacking the
pawn pawn is
pinned I'm preserving Bishop B5 which I
think I'll go for in this
position uh there was a question I'll
maybe try and answer this after the game
but why I wasn't taking on
F7 um the short answer is there were
more juicy targets or juicier targets to
to
pursue um but I probably could have gone
away with taking and would have been
fine okay so
[Music]
now I can go for Pawn takes Pawn or
Knight
D5
let's go for Pawn takes
Pawn King F6
okay of it's very very close to
checkmates I think it's Checkmate in
two yeah I'm pretty sure this is force m
in two I'm already controlling a lot of
squares around the
king E6 is the one square that's not
controlled but the natural continuation
here is
D5 forcing the king
E6 and
then then there should be check in
one yeah Queen to
E4 nice kind of aesthetic
mate King got a little bit uh
exploitable early on this
game um yeah in the final position a lot
of pisos are playing a role in the
mates Bishop both Bishops Knight the
queen Pawn is nice having on
D6 anyway this game was a nice example
of kind of how to punish a slow opening
from black like H6 is surprisingly
common at this rating level I think
partly because a lot of players struggle
with this fried liver type line like
Knight G5
Etc so usually what I recommend for
players that are scared of the early
Knight G5 is you can start with Bishop
C5 and then Queen controls G5 if white
plays this then you can play this and
then Knight G5 is met with
castling but what happened in this game
was yeah I open the center got the early
lead in
development black just had the queen out
early and then yeah so so here there are
a few moments where I could have taken
the pawn if I take it
here then Queen takes
E4 and this is not what I want like with
the queen trade then black is coping a
bit more
easily
so I move back to just avoid trading
queens and then here yeah I guess I
could have taken I'll be honest I didn't
even consider it uh
um like sometimes early on you you just
want to focus on peace activity and
development more than uh more than
material especially if the material
isn't isn't that
valuable uh so with
G3 yeah I was really just going
for quick initiative like attack the
queen develop the bishop to attack the
pawn and that led to just a quicker way
to win the
game
so hopefully everything makes
sense another smooth
game question from light vet can you
please explain Knight B5 Knight takes
E4 and then Knight
C7 ah okay that's actually a good
point black could have considered
taking and then okay it's it's not a
good move and we go through why but it's
tricky because black is threatening F2
here if I play this and King
d8
and
then yeah it's risky to take the Rook
because then I'm subjecting myself to
Queen takes
F2 um I think G3 is actually a nice way
to solve the problems like attack the
queen and then just get ready to take
the Rook the next move and there's just
too many too many Targets in in the
position so G3 is a nice kind of in
between move ensuring that I'm not
losing
F2 so um let's move on two games
in let's do
another playing line on the
left
E4 sticking with principal
openings playing Knight
C6 and we have a
Spanish I've encountered the Spanish a
few times uh in this series and I'm
going to go for the um not the main line
This is called the stinus defense Pawn
D6 and one of the reasons I I go for
this um partly is because I I learned
this when I was younger it's one of the
first openings I learned against the
Spanish but there's also a really nice
trap that can emerge from from this
exact
position and D4 of course looked
attractive for white now White's not
falling into the Trap uh the Trap
usually occurs after Bishop B3 and I can
explain after the game with
D5 white is
counterattacking and now it's
interesting because I have to choose
whether to save the Knight and allow
white to save the bishop or take the
bishop and then go into some
weird situation
where I'll have double pawns but white
will have this Pawn on
C6 um I'm going to take the bishop even
though these pawns look really
ugly uh the prospect of just winning the
ca Pawn I think is enough to go for
this and the idea is yeah if
I guess if Bishop G5 then I'll hopefully
be able to get out of the
pin I was going to say if C3 I would
take take and then Bishop
D7 so
[Music]
here I mean generally you should be very
very careful playing a move like
F6 because it can very often weaken the
king in this case I think it's
Justified to Simply break the pin attack
the
bishop and then next move take the
pawn and another point I wanted to make
like another reason why I went for this
trade of Bishop for Knight is that long
term I have the two
Bishops which at least from my
observations like stronger players
usually put more favor towards having
the bishop
hair and it can definitely make a
difference later in the
game so going forward from here let's
develop Play Bishop
G4 and pinning the
Knight Queen D5 it looks
scary uh but I can probably respond with
Queen
[Music]
D7 white is maybe going to win the pawn
back like already here I can start
applying pressure go for Knight
D4
attacking the pinned
Knight and the strategy might be
to like just focus on a quick kingside
attack like when the time is right take
with one of the pieces on
F3 damage white structure and then try
and get the queen
in if I can somehow get the queen to the
G file or to
H3
then maybe there will be mating
ideas so here yeah this is a very common
mistake White's trying to maybe force
matters on the the king side make my
Bishop decide what to do but in playing
H3 this Pawn is
overworked and I can
take and after takes back I can take on
H3 and I'll win a pawn and just open the
king in the
process
and because this comes with check yeah
white can't take the
bishop
so I'm actually up two pawns white still
hasn't won this Pawn back it's not a
pawn I really care
about um but it's still a question like
how
to actually formulate a plan on the king
side of course I'd love to teleport my
queen to
G2
but life isn't that
easy even if I teleport to G6 there's
Bishop
here I mean G5 comes to mind G5 Bishop
G3
H5 is definitely one
approach I might just have to be patient
here kind of accept the fact that I
won't be mating so soon my king is
relatively safe in the center for the
time being so I'm not in so much rush to
Castle although there is kind of an
interesting plan of playing Bishop E7
and then
F5 offer the bishop
trade and then maybe I can more easily
get the queen
[Music]
in I don't want to be in the spot like
Bishop here and then Queen
D5 I guess then Rook
B8
I also don't want to overthink things so
I think I I will play this
move trying to be somewhat efficient
with
development also identifying that this
bishop is my worst piece cuz all my
Pawns in the center are are on dark
Spurs so if I can get an F5 and trade
that off it would make life a bit
easier um yeah white preserving the
bishop
thinking I might as well throw in this
move like not even giving white a chance
to take on A4 Queen is useful
here okay white quickly plays Knight
D5 now I don't want to play a brain dead
move like C6 because this would walk
into Knight
B6 I think I'll I'll just move back I'll
focus in the center Bishop
E6 super solid here
and maybe gradually prepare like Rook B8
and then
C6 okay white
takes so I'm actually very very happy to
trade off that really bad Bishop for
White's like pretty active
Knight not sure what king F1 intends to
do maybe running the
king to the
center I'm going to start pushing Pawn
H5
going for Pawn
H4 Bishop H4 does prevent Pawn H4 but
ironically it's going to still allow
Pawn H4 and H4 comes with Tempo so
White's losing a bit of time this bishop
is basically a dead piece cuz uh it's
completely restricted even moving to G1
it's sped by its
pawn and now
here I'm actually debating like I have a
couple uh Bishop checks Bishop H3 or
Bishop
C4 and because I'm not sure which bishop
move to play I'm just going to hold off
I know my Rook likes to be on open
vile this is one of the pluses of having
double pawns it does open up the line
for the
rook
and maybe later where it's more
clear I'll have a a better idea where
the bishop wants to
go also have to watch my time sometimes
the downside of doing these speed runs
is I take a lot of time explaining every
move and then get a little bit low on
time
so and still about four minutes
oops to make sure I don't mess up the
layout
too opponent taking time here plays Pawn
to
B3 which does save the
[Music]
pawn also prevents Bishop
C4 I don't really want to take and allow
the file to open for
whites I'm going to play Queen
D7 I it moved to E7 to recapture but I
think it's just better on the Square
because it it also has potential to use
these
diagonals
one plan might be to
play this G4
move to get rid of this Pawn to open the
G file maybe put the Rook on
G8 okay Rook
E3 I'm start with Rook
G8 that's kind of like the com before
the storm I'm just trying to optimize
the pieces to get ready for the eventual
Pawn
break like sometimes before you you try
and open the position you just want to
make sure all the pieces are on their
optimal
squares and Rooks either like to be on
open files or files which are likely to
open and because I control the the like
when I go for this break then um I can
control when the file opens andan the
king's going to have a safe place if it
wants to move to
E2 it's somewhat hard to
exploit I guess another thing I should
point out is it's so nice having all my
pawns at least all these pawns on dark
squares CU it compliments my Bishop so
I'm maximizing the number of squares I'm
controlling and I'm restricting White's
Bishop so like generally when there's op
color Bishops you do want to be be
conscientious of where you put your
pawns or what color you put your pawns
on um going for this move just defending
A6 exerting pressure against
C2 if takes I would have the the pin
Bishop
C4 oh and here wow White's walking into
a double pin Bishop C4
anyway it's actually a really aesthetic
move this pin and this
pin did not see that coming up until
White had already played Rook
B1 but very Feelgood
[Music]
move so if white takes on C4 with the
queen I'll take take and then go up
material I'm basically winning a rook
for Bishop
regardless yeah and we'll simplify into
the end
game
I haven't lost a single Pawn
yet still have all eight pawns white
maybe wants to go for
this uh but now I can trop the
bishop yeah The Rook has snuck in from
behind and once I win the bishop then it
should be pretty straightforward to
Queen the pawn unless the bishop moves
here then I guess I'm losing my first
Pawn of the game
but now the other Rook is ready to come
in King's going to
run so I do want to be efficient with
the conversion
here no way for white to defend
A2 I mean the goal is probably to win A2
and then look to Queen this Pawn there
also might be some mating ideas with the
other Rook coming in
yeah if I get both Rooks on the second
rank they can start to
coordinate White's still trying to fight
I mean trying to make sure I can't
easily Queen
but yeah now C2 is going to be the next
victim and once the Rooks get
connected I think there's bound to be
some mating
ideas like here I'll take with the a
rook and I'm threatening Maiden
one don't have to worry about any stal
me I mean white has a lot of legal
moves and this is
checkmates
okay uh pretty smooth
game I see a comment about Rook
A3 there are a lot of ways to win Rook
A3 runs into C3 so Rook C2 is a bit more
efficient um but yeah that was a kind of
a nice strategic positional
battle I think I got the early Edge out
of the
opening um if we just go
back I feel like I've shown this line at
least a few times across the various
speedrun
episodes but for anyone that missed it
or hasn't seen this line before
D4 is arguably a small mistake for what
I mean a lot of players will stumble
into this thinking it looks good the
knight's pinned D5 is a threat Pawn
takes Pawn is a threat if takes and
takes um but a lot of players will
stumble into this line with
B5 my opponent played D5 which I think
is one of the best moves but if Bishop
B3 then this sequence is the Noah's Arc
trap if white takes here which is like
the big blunder then there's C5
Queen
D5 looks like maybe Black's in trouble
but Bishop E6 defending mate and
defending the Rook Queen C6 Bishop D7
Queen goes back and then
C4 and then black is winning a
piece so I've had this position a good
amount or this trap a good amount over
the course of my my early chess
career um and what happened to game I
think was in just kind of a different
path in this
opening I won the pawn I exerted
pressure I won another pawn and this
bishop was kind of dead for most of the
game but still took
patience to kind of build up the
advantage so I'm scanning through chat
trying to look for
questions there's a question from
gymster could someone explain what
overworked means yeah this very common
Concept in
chess overworked simply refers
to uh it's usually a piece that's doing
a few too many jobs in the
position usually a piece that's
defending too many things in the
position in this case the pawn was
defending H3 and
F3 and the typical way to take advantage
of an overworked piece is to
take one thing make it make the G2 Pawn
do its job on F3 and then win the other
thing on
H3 and you see this not only with pawns
being overworked but any piece can be
overworked um and
sometimes like before you even see a
tactic you'll just identify that
something over something is overworked
and that will lead you to spotting the
tactic so I hope that makes sense anyway
uh I think I'm going to wrap it up up
here for this
episode I hope people enjoyed watching
on Twitch hope you guys learned a thing
or
two uh I guess I can
show I
show twitch chat for future YouTube
audience thank you Chessmaster the last
minute bits yeah if you're watching in
the future on YouTube don't forget to
follow on Twitch I sometimes will live
stream these episodes do a lot of other
live content as well
maybe someday hopefully some sometime
this year I'll experiment with streaming
on YouTube as
well just got to look into technical
setup and yeah a lot of energy I
appreciate people being awake maybe
there's some people who have fallen
asleep at this
point but stay tuned for
more